llegamos al viernes y es momento de
hablar de economía quien france24 y es
por ello que recibo y con mucho gusto
daniel hablando ramírez la especialista
económica daniela empezamos en india si
te parece bien y es que miles de
campesinos bloquearon carreteras para
protestar por las nuevas condiciones
para vender sus productos así es alan
muy buenas noches especialmente en los
estados de punjab y haryana que producen
la mayor parte del trigo del país es una
ley que acaba de ser aprobada en el
parlamento dice o permite más bien a los
grandes comerciantes adquirir productos
directamente de los agricultores hasta
el momento el esquema funciona de la
siguiente manera los productos son
vendidos a los mercados mayoristas con
precios mínimos regulados por el
gobierno luego pasan por un
intermediario para venderlos a los
grandes empresarios pues la controversia
radica en que ahora con estas reformas
alan los precios serán libres y no habrá
intermediarios el gobierno dice que esto
traerá un mercado más abierto pero los
granjeros temen que vayan a perder poder
de negociación con las grandes empresas
de alimentos
imponiendo precios más baratos vámonos
con las tensiones comerciales de las dos
mayores economías del mundo daniela y es
que más de tres mil compañías demandaron
al gobierno de eeuu por imponer
aranceles a china fueron exactamente
unas 3500 compañías entre ellas tesla
ford target walgreens y home depot
estas empresas han demandado a la
administración trump en las últimas dos
semanas por la imposición de aranceles a
más de trescientos mil millones de
dólares en productos fabricados en china
concretamente el descontento radica
sobre el 25 por ciento de arancel que se
impuso sobre 200 mil millones de dólares
y también sobre el 7.5 por ciento sobre
otros 120 mil millones esto en el marco
de la guerra comercial por supuesto con
china esas empresas
recordemos que dependen mucho de los
insumos provenientes del país asiático
lo que cuestionan es lo que llaman una
escalada ilegal de impuestos que dicen
ni siquiera respeto los 12 meses
reglamentarios entre uno y otro y
tampoco cumplió con las normas
administrativas
seguimos hablando de estos temas de
impuestos y de la escalada de tensiones
y es que la comisión europea retomó la
batalla legal para obligar a apple a
pagar una millonaria suma bueno esta
pelea que data del 2016 tiene que ver
con impuestos por casi 15 mil millones
de dólares que el gigante estadounidense
no pagó en irlanda entre 2013 y 2014
2003 mejores y 2014 cuando comenzó la
disputa la comisión europea concluyó que
apple recibió una serie de beneficios
que hicieron que pagara menos impuestos
pues el bloque comunitario dice que si
esas ventajas se le dan a una empresa se
les tienen que dar a todas el pasado 15
de julio el tribunal en general de la
unión europea le dio la razón a apple y
dijo que la comisión europea no aportó
las suficientes pruebas para demostrar
que hubo un favorecimiento ilegal por
eso hoy este organismo comunitario
anunció que llevará el caso al tribunal
de justicia
seguimos en europa y es que la pandemia
afectó las finanzas de la corona
británica daniela así es alan los
confinamientos el reino unido
que se desplomaran las visitas o mejor
que no hubiera visitas tampoco a las
residencias reales como el palacio de
buckingham y el castillo de windsor en
su informe financiero anual la corona
real informó que en los próximos tres
años tendrá un déficit de casi 38 mil
millones de euros de ese total 16,2
millones son por la ausencia de
visitantes y el resto por los costos
asociados a la renovación de la
residencia de la reina isabel entre las
medidas que se están analizando para
sortear esta escasez de recursos alan
está por ejemplo la de congelar los
salarios del personal de la realeza lo
que no aparece entre las opciones es el
subsidio soberano de la monarca que es
como su salario y que en el último año
fue de 99 90 millones de euros mostrar
los indicadores económicos de anela o
street del cerro en positivo pero
acumula cuatro semanas seguidas de
pérdidas guiadas por los bruscos
movimientos de las tecnológicas en
europa los nuevos confinamientos siguen
afectando las plazas bursátiles que
culminaron la semana a la baja
latina hubo ligeras ganancias en
argentina y méjico y una pérdida muy
ligera en salvar yo y cuál es tu cifra
del día para finalizar bueno son 10
millones de coronas suecas es decir 1,1
millones de dólares que subió este año
el aporte económico para los ganadores
del premio nobel le subieron casi un 10%
alan gracias a que las finanzas se han
podido estabilizar en el último año
según dijo la fundación muy bien daniela
pues muchas gracias por el recorrido
económico y ustedes por su compañía
sigue en francés 24
y